bonjour ya elle ne craint merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france tout
d'abord est ce que vous êtes satisfait
du montant de cette prime qui devrait
être de 100 euros net par mois en plus
du salaire comme l'annoncé gérald
darmanin alors satisfait de la non d'une
prime oui là où on serait pleinement
satisfait c'est que la prime soit versée
comme elle l'a été à mons et c'est à
dire à l'ensemble des personnels qui ont
concouru avec risque au lied et c'est là
que le bât blesse puisque la prime n'est
pas attribué de manière uniforme sur
l'ensemble du territoire et pas de
manière uniforme au sein même des
personnels donc l'annnonce de la prime
louis l'application on est un petit peu
plus circonspect
lorsqu'on parle de 15% de pompier 1 qui
pourront toucher cette prime qui est
concerné exactement et bien en principe
les pompiers qui ont été impactés par le
cos vise ceux qui ont continué leurs
activités de secours quotidien le score
à victimes constitue 82% notre activité
donc naturellement nous avons été en
première ligne puisque nous sommes déjà
au quotidien
la première ligne dans dans le saut
course et c'est nous quels sont les
personnels concernés sont les personnels
qui sont censées avoir été vraiment au
contact des ducs au vide et là c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué à déterminer
certains départements ont décidé
d'attribuer cette prime à ça
la plupart des leur personnel et notre
département font de la dentelle en
essayant de distinguer quelles sont les
personnalités ont vraiment été sur les
interventions identifié comme étant
vraiment qu vide pour pouvoir attribuer
cette prime d'où le ressenti un petit
peu négatif d'une partie de la
population qui se sent délaissée ayant
été malgré tout exposé en tout cas
présent au travail pour assurer la crise
mobile parce qu'il s'agit bien d'une
prime kovy d'ehpad une revalo des
revalorisations de la prime de fait
comme on a pu le voir tout à fait un
texte d'accord tout à fait ce sont deux
choses tout à fait différentes la prime
de feu
un dossier que nous travaillons depuis
longtemps et qui aboutit enfin et là
aussi on observe que les collectivités
locales sont un petit peu frileuse à
verser cette prime malgré les annonces
il faut à chaque fois aller chercher ces
informations et pour les pompiers de
paris par exemple nous avions demandé la
gratuité pendant le prime qu'ovide celle
ci a été accordée au personnel
nan mais pas du tout aux
sapeurs-pompiers voilà vous avez le
contexte est ce que vous prévoyez des
actions pour réclamer que cette prime
soit étendue à tous alors en ce qui
concerne notre syndicat nous avons écrit
à bon nombre de présidents de conseil
d'administration par exemple celui du
nord a reçu un courrier l'interrogeant
sur ses intentions et nous n'avons pas
de réponse dire que les administrations
peine à se positionner sur cette prime
je pense qu'on tend un petit peu sur sur
le temps qu'il a passé pour que les
personnels l'oubli et passe un peu à
autre chose donc privilégiant le
dialogue nous attendons que nos
sollicitations trouvent réponse alors on
l'a dit les pompiers sont en première
ligne face aux cours et la virus est ce
que vous craignez une seconde vague est
ce que vous êtes préparés à une
éventuelle seconde vague alors notre
travail c'est de se préparer en
permanence
sauf que le colis était une crise que
personne n'avait dit mentionner de
manière certaine donc nous nous
préparons les stocks de matériel arrive
dans les services d'incendié et de
secours
l'approvisionnement est parfois encore
un petit peu tendue sur certains types
de matériels ou doit remplacer un
matériel par un autre jeu ça pose
quelques problèmes dans l'est dans les
services incendie
mais néanmoins nous sommes nous sommes
près des gens ont compris les mesures
barrières nos sapeurs pompiers sont là
pour pour sauver dans toute circonstance
et c'est ce qu'ils feront malgré le co
lead merci beaucoup y est le crack pour
toutes ces précisions je rappelle que
vous êtes sapeurs-pompiers vice
président du syndicat des pompiers
professionnels
merci merci